well hello and thank you for watching
this presentation on a dose of a flu
influences variable virus particles in
this presentation we'll be talking about
what it is makes influenza viruses
infectious which of course are the virus
particles are in transit and it's worth
perhaps starting by looking back quite a
long way in time and looking at the way
people have considered what makes him so
under infectious over long code after
all this is these which has been with us
for a long time there's been conspicuous
for a long time so the way we think
about it as for a long time reflected
the best of the way we understand how
diseases are caused the name itself
comes from an early modern realization
that diseases were caused not by some
internal reflection of ozone States but
by external effects acting on e
influenza is from a medieval Latin for
an influence an external influence
acting on a region and causing people
that become sick what that influence was
was not initially clear as well but it
might perhaps be an unfortunate
alignment to the Stars or other ideas
which have gone since out of use but
that idea was correct and developed over
time the influence became physical with
the idea that perhaps people being
sickened by foul airs or my asthma's or
related concepts like zymogens and
unpleasant particles stirred into the
air this at least was correct him it had
posited a physical cause but it couldn't
explain a number of features of the way
this disease spreads for example the
fact that quarantines work and it once
early epidemiological studies of viral
spread started coming in it became
harder and harder to explain how
influenza viruses could spread across
countries if they were transmitted in
this way and so ideas might aswel
crowded out by an idea which was in many
ways radically odd at the time the idea
that diseases were caused not by foul
smells or things easily apprehended but
by invisibly tiny things which ganged up
on you and made you sick the germ theory
of disease are so successful explaining
influenza
that by the time with great influenza of
1918 it was very clear in most people's
minds what might cause for disease it
was clearly going to be caused by
bacterium so clear in fact with Rick our
fight for one of the most eminent
bacteriologist VH went so far as to find
bacteria in question which we now called
mufflers and clones I even at the time
though is clear that as an explanation
this was lacking something although
bacterial infections certainly made
cases of infants of worse and that
remains true to this day they were not
clearly causative of me illness what
actually caused enzymes that took a
little bit longer to find it was first
identified in burden to others when
swine influences and finally in the
1930s two groups realized that human
influences could infect ferrets and
using the system you can see here a
ferret sneezing once it's been infected
they were able to isolate the cause of
influenza and to show that it was caused
by there is still relatively recent
concept a virus and why we think they
are virus we all have a fairly clear
idea what we're talking about we're
talking an extremely small infectious
particle and the idea David imprinted
was caused by a virus came in in the
early days of biology and also in the
early days in molecular biology which is
an ideal time to start studying a virus
because viruses of parasites are
attacked on a molecular level so we have
now a clear understanding of what causes
influenza but it is what this means have
continued to evolve over time and this
talk we're going to look at two aspects
really in the way in which thinking of
influenza virus can still be over
simplified and some of the ways in which
more advanced modern methods can give us
a clearer idea of what's going on the
first simplification is to assume that
most virus particles are extremely
simple and extremely identical now it is
true up to a point for a number of
viruses we can see here for example
adenovirus
this is one one of a number of very
regular the virus is formed from
interlocking virally encoded components
so regular in fact they can be forming
into crystals and solved in atomic
detail that way influenza viruses like
many medically important viruses are not
like this the virus particles of Lorenza
transmit influenza are an enveloped bag
scooped up from the cell containing a
mixed shelled viral and host components
in variable ratios this makes it much
harder to determine exactly what is
present in any individual virus particle
another way in which we can send someone
to over simplify abuser virus is when we
start thinking about what virus particle
actually do now we know roughly what
they do the virus particle is the
station of our replication cycle where
the viral genes which have taken over
one cell and turned it essentially into
a factory for producing more copies of
the virus is packaged into a barley
encoded component the virus particle of
that transmitted infection for another
cell now what you can see a cup of talk
is a way of taking that microscopic
event and making it visible this is a
plaque I think this is one of the first
buck assays applying to influenza many
of you may be familiar with those but if
you're not this is a system where if
influenza virus possible affects a cell
and it's maintained under the right
conditions
that cell will infect its neighboring
cells and their neighboring cells and
their effect their living cells and can
you have an affected region
largely invisible and they can die and
you can see those plaques there this is
an enormous leap powerful way of
studying viruses and in fact in this
paper from 1950s sorry in 1960s which
was used for applying packets from
influenza just the application of our
method was enough to show the virus
could infect cells with single hits
kinetics and to define the kinetics of
as far as possible to shout from a cell
you can learn a lot very quickly that
way but essays like this as we will see
later direct our attention solely to the
first round of both bara application
they can cause us to miss a lot some
more complicated effects which are
likely to be taking place in a natural
infection so in this talk we'll be
asking some questions about what is an
influenza bearing what is that Mazda
virus particle was trying this
from oneself next we have already our
basic idea that influence is transmitted
by these these bars possible these small
boxes full of barbed genes but we'll
show that by applying one methods we can
look in more detail at the complex
structure which transmits far as
possible from one cell to ness and then
we can look at unexpected sources of
variation among influence variants and
think about the bit about what
implications that might have called
spread of the virus now before I start I
just like to say a little bit about
where most of this work took place this
is the MRC University of Glasgow centre
of the virus research which as name was
suggested in the city of Glasgow in
Scotland and United Kingdom and I run a
research group there but other people I
work with they're very good scientists
mean work I'm going to talk about here
is quite wide-ranging and so we're
fortunate to collaborate with a lot of
people both within the central virus
research which is the is largest
concentration of human investment
biologists so we have a lot of people
working in different ways but also
beyond the CVR as well so here here are
my group and within this talk in
particular some of the national scene
has come from David Beller
Pablo Murcia and then beyond the CVR
collaborators at University of Oxford
who worked on proteomics
Terry Smith isn't Andrews who's working
at the doughnuts some very talented
students at Brussels who works who
doesn't visualization work and all this
work was funded by the UK's Medical
Research Council
so together what we've been looking at
well we've been looking at influenza
virus particles and as you can see from
this electron micrograph
they are not uniform bodies by any means
but they vary continuously in their size
and the shape so we need to find a way
which will allow us to examine in detail
what they're actually made of and one
approach to this is to purify very large
numbers of them analyze their
composition events take that competition
as a measure of the average properties
of an individual period so to do this
you first need a large amount of
five virus over some fairly standard
methods to do this you can grow up a
large amount of virus by infecting cell
cultures we did this here a roller
bottom wishes Illustrated there to get
as large amount of virus containing cell
growth media as possible bubbles
contains a lot of dead cells so firstly
clarified by low-speed centrally Gatien
to bring out debris when we concentrate
the virus by ultracentrifugation take
that through a sucrose brilliant which
gives us a nice clear band of virus
particles you can see a picture about on
the right and that can be drawn off and
concentrated again and as you can see
why the silver stained block that
produces lots and lots of viral material
in this case this jealous shown protein
then using this concentration smart
material we can start to examine what
those virus particles and made on
firstly we can look at their dimensions
here by prior electron microscopy you
can see that volume and you can see that
that's occupies a fairly narrow range
for this burst is talking about or not
identical in size and they do have a
consistent means mean volume and that we
can look at their various components so
influenza viruses and what's referred to
as enveloped viruses which means they've
taken up membrane from the host cell but
as miss lipid ohmic shows that membrane
that has a different composition
specifically bits from the bulk
composition of being packed itself you
can also look at the proteins by mass
spectrometry and we can quantify those
proteins as well and all these proteins
have had their structures sold in
individual studies and where gaps exist
in structures we've been able to model
them in so you can see those Illustrated
there I don't have time in this
presentation to explain in detail the
ways in which these cross check against
other estimates approaching the bundles
and ovarian but I can tell you that this
method gets all those values pretty
accurately with the exception of those
spikes on the surface of the virus
possible the glycoproteins for which we
have to estimate the abundance by
microscopy and by counting them as you
can see not an image there so we now
have
an estimation of a proteins present in
the self the brown bar on the right is a
little bit of a worry though because
that brown bar on the right is the
abundance of host proteins in our
preparation of iris and you can see
rather a loss of some host proteins
inside the virus was not too surprising
but we will not expect in sequence and
money so of course at this point we had
to ask ourselves exactly how clean was
our preparation of Baris and a simple
waiting list is to take our nice Bandar
virus which I showed you before and to
compare a similar preparation from the
media of uninfected cells and if we draw
off the equivalent banned from the
gradient if we've done a mock
introduction and run up the proteins of
both bounds on Jen
gel and sustain them you can see very
strong bamming of protein for the virus
infected prep bars on the left and on
the right you can see almost nothing in
the media from Bach infected cells
almost but not quite if you look very
carefully about journals see a few faint
bands on there now some stains are very
sensitive but mass spectrometry now is a
lot more sensitive than that so what we
can do instead is to start comparing our
samples by mass spectrometry before we
do that though it's we want to try and
vary the stringency about purification
if as you can see indicated here we have
a mixture of both foreign particles and
other material chevron cells could we
find a way of separating amber two and
to do this we use an adaptation of the
very old method which I think has been
largely abandoned since the 1960s which
is to chill our virus and mix it with
red blood cells
pratik purification the reason for doing
this is red blood cells are coated with
silac us in the protein viruses bind to
to get into cells but they don't
actually take up the post so the virus
will stick to the surface of the red
blood cells and if we do this we can
bind all the virus to red blood cells
and when you can we can wash away
everything it isn't virus from those
cells and we can then rinse those cells
a few times
those who just want Baris pamphlets all
sixes and nothing else and then we can
warm them up and the reason for doing
this is that at four degrees the virus
is able to bind systolic acid and then
it just sits there the Meritor satisfy
that custom cleaving activity promised
nerman days the end protein which
balances out the binding activity VHA or
each protein on the surface and virus
which binds to the salic acid this
allows the virus to cleave it stuff off
from an infected cell when newly formed
bars particles are formed about numeron
there's activity from um a protein is
quite slow at four degrees it's
extremely slow so the virus will just
sit there if we now warn these red blood
cells up to 37 degrees weinerman it
becomes a lot more active the virus
drops opera this means that we've now
selected for material which both has
receptor binding activity to balance red
blood cells that receptor cleaning out
that deep Cleveland self offer them and
we can then purify it as before based on
its size so we now have a virus particle
size material which also has viral
proteins or the function of our
approaches on the surface if we apply
this slightly barak and convoluted
method to our clarifications we get a
big change you can see here
mass spectrometry measurements of
material from our original experiments
and in the infected sample we can see
both viral proteins and blue and host
proteins in red and in the mock infected
sample obviously no viral proteins and
then some host proteins but about a
hundred fold less force and logarithmic
scale so barely detectable on silver
stain clearly in step although by mass
spectrometry if we now require material
to bind to red blood cells we can see
that some of the host proteins do get
washed away from the viruses so there
were some contaminants in there there
mainly histones from cellular debris and
rather than proteins
ribosomal proteins from probably Paula
zones but we can see in the mock
infected sample almost all of our host
proteins are washed away this takes us
down another hundred fold right down to
the limits of detection with the
instrument so we know we have very very
clean prep and we know that
remains in those virus particles is
genuinely part of mubarak possible
despite being proteins which is stolen
from its host so what are those proteins
well interestingly if we compare just
the host proteins now that are present
in the stringently purified virus
particles to those presence those
proteins present in the mock infected
sample without stringent purification
you can see that it's the same set of
proteins there's more of him in the
virus prep but they're in roughly the
same ratio in other words the virus
particles strongly resemble material
which for hosts is shedding anyway
what's going on here well actually this
is not a totally novel idea the
paleontologist Stephen Jay Gould in a
linked career departure from
paleontology published an article on HIV
in which he discussed about the HIV was
capable of taking up host proteins and
with his usual rhetorical clerestory
variants might be becoming trojan
exosomes in other words there might be
shrouding and salt and host dried
material in order to sneak into new
cells whether or not that's functionally
the case is probably still up for debate
but it's certainly the case that large
particles strongly resemble material
share themselves specifically we look by
pile up from micrograph which you can
see here and this is an illustration
version of what you're looking at there
the virus particles strongly resemble
microvesicles
small membrane bands these holes which
cells routinely shed in fact in many
ways in influenza virus basketball is
the microscope which has become
extremely packed full of virally encoded
proteins so also separated in my crease
calls away we can be confidently have an
accurate measurement of those proteins
to present within the virus particles so
we know how measurements of the size of
virus particles and we know what's in
there so we can now start to assemble a
model of what an average very month look
like so we can take unfix variants in
vitreous ice and image and by PI
electron microscopy you can see those
here my spy proteins on the surface
layers of membrane and underneath
latinamerican barrel matrix in the
genome in slant we can take all those
layers and look at the different
densities government what positions
those occur and we can then start
docking viral proteins in turnips
producing a 3d model of what an average
virus might look like laughter proteins
they're underneath the membrane
underneath that bar matrix and inside
that Barham gene then if we segment
images that variants we can work out
roughly what's almost layers but look
like and finally when we end up with a
detailed pseudo atomic 3d model of an
influenza virus particle why do you this
well on the one hand it's quite
aesthetically pleasing and indeed
because this project had various party
people involved with it we've been oh
jeez various resources for science
communication on there from current
books do to schools materials needing
through to a virtual viruses app and you
can find all of those if you're
interested on the CVR website but there
are science reasons for doing this as
well so we have as I said a the model
now of what New England's Marion is it
resembles and shields shared from cells
but it's enriched with viral components
as well but through the process of
spelling that we also started finding
points in which variation can be found
in that structure and I'd like to talk
about three fairly briefly now one is
the viral and it's one protein another
is the presence of host proteins and
finally the viral genome so we'll start
with Ellis one this is the virus's main
immune suppressive protein if it fills a
large number of roles but it really
helps to tamp down the immune response
in infected cells and nf1 stands for non
structural protein one in other words a
non structure protein this moment should
not be found inside virus particles so
you are a bit surprised to find it there
so we wondered if we just make a mistake
but the detection is unambiguous those
black lines indicate peptides of
approach and identified by mass
spectrometry
we can also detect by Western blossoms
of various different landing parties
okay so it's there in the prep but is it
there
with the virus particles well if we look
at where it comes on most agreements it
comes down at the same point as other
proteins between oh must be inside the
virus particle let them race I can also
hunt proteins inside the very unlikely
actin so it is there as part of the
virus particles okay
well it's there with the virus particles
but could it be in something else in
separately in the de brie well some of
it was in the package but even once he
purified the my criticals why it's still
there could it be stuck to the outside
of virus particles well once again
though if we digest our prep the
proteases NS one is degraded no more
quickly than bara proteins which we know
to be inside so we know that NS 1 is
present inside virus particles now
although this was a bit of a surprise
issue be said that influenza virologist
have formed in this regard we used to be
an NS - which is not a reproach was any
team as meirelles and that was present
in sight the fact that Ennis one is
there has led to a number of interesting
questions until now actively exploring
one is what it does just in to have some
effects but the other is to what extent
is its incorporation to virus particles
fixed and bouncer isn't it seems to vary
quite a bit we probably haven't come out
hopefully just next week which will
travel in pairings between different
strains of the virus another source of
variation is the incorporation of host
proteins influenza is well known for its
position about different hosts
notoriously can jump from species to
species and called pandemics which means
it has the option to take up different
host proteins and so we compared
influenza groans growing cells from a
variety of different host and also from
chicken eggs and we found when we did
that there are some host proteins which
are incorporated at the same regardless
of the system do you grow the men we
called Leiby called Lisi cool protein of
the virus but there are other proteins
which are quite distinctive so some
proteins you can see here in green which
you only get you go there are some
chicken eggs others she only you have to
get to be government cells of we
initially ourselves from cows and dogs
we've since extended that work quite a
bit in a work which is unpublished with
little work
within the lab and so we found that in
phones that has a clearly described cool
proteome of host drug proteins which can
be reliably found there all time but
there are also variable components we
shouldn't vary quite a bit from host
host to host perhaps the most striking
these are the membrane proteins of the
Tetris Palin family which are abundant
in there is their presence at levels
similar to about nerman days when
protein I mentioned before and exactly
which members of this protein come neat
you get depends very much on whether you
grow them in so on through different
species or in unrelated chicken eggs you
may if you you're watching this cause
you're new to influenza wonder why I
keep motioning embryo nation chicken
eggs which are not a natural host for
the virus and there are two reasons to
this one is that these are main system
we have for growing influenza vaccines
in fact the paper will which should be
coming out next week in journal vaccine
we have applied this method to the
purification process of vaccines which
is quite similar to the purification
process which I've just shown you for
our lab work there our reason for doing
that was to assess the purification
process which works very well as we're
cleaning up the virus particle which is
what you'd expect there's a lot of a
safety data showing that these vaccines
don't contain the chicken proteins to be
much of a threat even to people beg
allergies however there is a number less
host proteins within the virus Pascal
which means that egg prone vaccine
strains are distinctively if you like
eggy in their fundamental properties
whether it actually matters is probably
not the case they were still known to be
immunogenic it does also affect their
fundamental biology though for many
years
eggs were not just used to go vaccines
they're also the primary route we had to
isolate influenza virus particles and
that means that most of the laboratory
strains been phones we have have adapted
to growing in inks where they'll pick up
different set of proteins and will have
the opportunity to change away from the
properties that have what's growing
themselves not throats and as we'll see
quite soon amis talk those laboratory
strains have become a lot different from
the one thing she gets natural
reflections a final source of variation
is variation incorporation of the genome
so implant has an RNA genome it has
eight segments of our language a little
work barrel chromosomes and those are
wrapped in double helical spirals around
a raw egg protein assembly together
these called bribe Anika protein
complexes or are in peace and those
eight segments each of them packaged
into its own RMP are packaged together
to form a bundle of RMPs which together
surprises the entire influenza virus
genome and this was something I've done
fairly early on were working is on the
influenza viruses when I was a graduate
student I was interested in how this
complete bundle of eight proteins got
into new cells something which I noticed
along the way and literally did much
with was noticing that if you infected
cells with perfectly normal influenza
viruses and you quite often got cells
which expressed some but not all of the
viral genes in other words it seemed
that they've been infected by viruses
where some of those genes have been
missing hopefully I didn't do a great
deal with this sometime and so in my
laboratory is now returning to but in
the meantime have been some very elegant
studies looking at what's going on here
and I'd like to highlight two here the
first is from Chris Brooke who worked as
a postdoc and is now working extensively
on working set up his own group and
Chris infected cells with around with
different influenza viruses and measured
their ability to express it and viral
proteins that he's looking here at four
vo genes and you can see here a
considerable proportion do not express
warm for when those viruses are infected
with just cells and pectin with just one
virus particle taking another approach
Simeone nakatsu and
he's carried out electron microscopy
studies of virus particles and showed
that physically you can see certain
genome segments missing in a large
proportion than all of those virus
particles so influenza virus particles
frequently lack at the complete genome
why does this matter to our
understanding of the virus well let's go
back now to plaque assays that's very
traditional extremely powerful virology
technique which has been applied to
influenza from the very early days of
study as a virus the logic of a plaque
assay is that an infection spreads to
the points that you can see the naked
eye as a result focusses can only see
infections where a single bharat
particle is capable of initiating an
infection all by itself
in other words Bukka [ __ ] assays can
only see fully and captures virus
particles and Chris Brooke a
demonstration is very elegantly in his
paper where he compared this is a fairly
early stage instead of plaques fully
infectious virus particles you can see
here at the top but an initial cell has
infected as neighbors and they started
from their neighbors that will go on to
form a plaque in compared bows to semi
infectious particles ones which can
initiate infections you can see there
but most infections will only in fact a
single cell and will never that never
spread recently will not spread it's
because they're missing one or more the
genes needed to produce new virus
particles now if you just have a single
virus particle entering a cell then it's
game over as far as the virus is
concerned when this happens and indeed
this is likely what happens quite often
at the point when you get infected by
the virus you're unlikely to receive a
large dose of virus that's getting
diluted at your throat the proportion of
our possible could make it to any
individual some your throat is going to
be really diluted down so those first
infections you get may well require
pullian structure as far as particles
but what happens next well that selling
your throat is going to start
producing lots more virus particles and
lovel enter the cells around the
potentially more or less simultaneously
some onsen infections are underway
within you their scope for interactions
when between multiple virus particles
entering cells at the same time and then
it turns out the properties of viruses
that come run different and as I said
most people work to mr. Chris exported
rather nicely by taking both semi
infectious virus particles and nature
I'm going to show you here look at the
expression of just two viral gene
proteins with themselves
the ancient Lian proteins are much from
the fall and he's going to increase
what's called the multiplicity infection
in other words the number of virus
particles per cell in the system and you
can see here when you have a lower mo AI
you have cells which fail to express
both of our proteins but as you increase
the multiplicity infection you get more
and more cells which are able to express
both far apart proteins at high levels
why is that well it's because large
particles which couldn't initiate
infections by themselves when they get
into a cell that cell has suddenly
received all of the neat genes it needs
to make a new virus in other words those
virus particles can interrupt so we need
to stop thinking on influenza virus
particles as being things which can
carry necessarily have to carry a
complete viral genome from one cell to
the next they can carry parts and they
can then interact to carry out
infections so the composition and
infectivity of influence variants is
actually quite a variable thing and that
leads us to think differently about how
those in terms of our particles want the
hang so this model is only a kind but
also is it accurate at all but from I
said we were going to look at the
average properties of a virus particle
but we started off with a very very
laboratory adapted strain of virus when
Pat one of the oldest strains of viruses
isolated in 1933 back when those first
parents sonia's I showed you earlier
were carried out and consistent with all
I showed you before in terms of their
size and we take those viruses and we
run them out on a density gradient we
can see there have very consistent
range all densities but if we take
slightly different strain of influenza
virus you run that out on density
gradient we have a rather different
distribution densities of bars particles
we have a peak here on less dense
variance what's going on here well
what's going on here so which has been
known for a long time in terms of our
ology but often overlooked this is an
extremely older from micrograph of the
buret readapted influence viruses and I
should now be familiar to you they're
roughly spherical in size and just over
100 nanometers across and this is a
settlement fund of our particles which
has been recently isolated from a
patient and you'll immediately see that
they are strikingly different you do
still have some of those small spherical
virus particles in there that you also
have extremely long filaments but these
small spherical particles are around 100
nanometers or 0.1 of the micro across
these filamentous influenza virus
particles meet tens of microns in length
and to show you some rather nice a
modern micrographs of them and one of
the left a Kinnear by Emily Bruce
showing tangles of these filaments
coming out of infected cells and on the
right a cry electron micrograph taken by
my colleagues feta media Christian we're
showing some relatively short filaments
but showing the internal organization of
them compared to shorter more spherical
particles filaments have been very
understudied
in influenza virus research one of the
main reasons for that is that they are
strongly selected against by growth in
eggs
quite possibly although we're not really
sure yet why because the protein
components incorporated into both virus
particles are so very different from
once you'd normally get and the
conditions they grow so a lot of the
strains we have in the lab and lost
their ability to produce these long
Munson's virus particles so that's one
problem so we can start to speculate
about what they might do that is quite
hard to know for sure one immediately
obvious question is are they in effect
just well some of them carry over genome
you can see this here in one of sweaters
cry electron micrographs but by no means
all of them she found plenty of others
which lack influenza genome along there
month this was done based on morphology
but recently in an extremely beautiful
piece of work Michael VAR he inserted
tags into various viral proteins which
could be fluorescently labeled and was
able to look for the presence here at
various proteins in influenza virus
particles in different morphologies and
as a prickly were rather confusing
micrograph of top there but if you look
here at the bottom you can see the
distribution of influenza virus
particles with them without genome marks
here by nuclear protein NP when they
have different months and you can see
here so the proportion of spherical
varies with the genome is quite high
whereas the proportion of filamentous
there is containing genome you
considerably lower
so these filaments are not necessarily
infectious
however they are present in most natural
Iceland and Boris moreover in fact some
really nice work from slightly Sherman
and colleagues with John Steele and
Ernie Sloan has shown that if you take
spherical viruses one of those have
adapted for laboratory gross and lost
their ability to form filaments and
searly assertions through any pigs they
me gain their abilities compliments if
you have doing something that's
important it's really hard to figure out
why one reason why is really hard to
figure out why is that we've come rather
late to filaments in the field we've
lacks many of the tools needed to
effectively study them in fact it's
often quite hard to know how many
filaments you even have in a prep as you
try to move from one experiment and next
and their presence seems to vary
a bit so our experimental results can
become quite hard to interpret we need
another way in other words a way of
measuring these filamentous particles
before we can even start working on them
this is what jock Hearst very talented
graduate student who's come to work with
me has been doing he's taken a
self-consciously old-fashioned approach
which is to say that these filaments are
so long you don't really need to use
electron microscopes you can start using
light microscopes look at them and but
be known for a long time using extremely
old lie micro dust and influenza
filaments jack has access to more
advanced technology so he's able to take
on focal micrographs of incontinence and
you can see these here this is pretty
for us but extremely concentrated image
of them when they're diluted he can
perform image analysis image and hassle
analysis on them defining the length of
filaments within a population this
allows him to start working out exactly
what filaments are present and then to
start laying out some of the basic tools
we can use in studying these previously
najin ignored virus particles it's one
of the first things Jack did was to test
whether most of our standard laboratory
handling procedures were okay for
working with elements and the good news
was that most of them were the bad news
is if you froze them which is something
we did pretty routinely will work
influenza viruses the filaments fall to
pieces with the lens and filaments drops
the concentration of filaments drops and
the filaments which remain go-jacks
razors kinky but they get
distortions long alone we've suggested
being damaged to their nuclear captain
this is pretty dismal news if you want
to either carry out from the work on
filaments yourself or go back and
interpret other studies in literature
and so of course the next thing Jack
needed to do is to find ways to prevent
them being damaged he found that you can
either snap freeze and watch
cryoprotectants that works up to a point
well you can just not freeze them at all
humans are quite physically stable and
even at room temperature although the
infected to embarrass to degrade rather
quickly under those conditions is not
shown here both infectivity and filament
quite stable in the fridge and if you
want to figure out exactly how to do
that in yourself Jax vapor is whether
read on that you can see that reference
there so we're now getting to the point
where we actually have a toolkit
available to ask what bees long
filaments are doing but for the time
being
their role in deflections remains a
mystery natural infections do involve
these long filaments experience but we
still don't yet know what they did so we
started with this rather straightforward
view of influenza variance this is a
sort of picture which most fairness
would sketch out believe you if you said
draught a virus particle does there are
small containers which transfer the
viral genes from one cell to the next
and I call about previous ways of
understanding influenza infections that
is true but only up to a point and it's
an electro science that I think closely
we have to elaborate and refine our
understanding what's going on to more
closely fit our ideas the way the world
actually works so yes it is true that
the influenza viruses are transmitted by
virus particles however and those
variants vary both Maasai's on their
composition they closely resemble
material shed from the host cell and
that means a different virus grows from
the host from different conditions those
virus particles will themselves vary and
finally although influenza variants can
initiating infection with just one of
them as infections start to spread and
concentrations of virus particles rise
they can compete and complement and
interact in previously unexplored ways
and as they get into cells so hopefully
you'll see from this talk that whilst we
now have a clear idea what influenza is
a virus is still a great deal more to do
in terms of understanding exactly what
that means as an influenza infection
spreads through your throat thank you
very much